-Welcome back, everybody.
Here at "The Tonight Show,"
we love songs.
And we especially love songs
written by
our great audience members
in under an hour.
It's time for "Battle of the
Instant Songwriters."
-♪ Sing a song
and I'm singing a song ♪
♪ And I'm writing a song
about another song ♪
-Welcome to "Battle of the
Instant Songwriters."
Before the show, we went through
our audience and picked out
two people who said that they
were musicians.
We gave them each
a made-up song title
then gave them an hour to write
an original song
based on that title.
Here's a shot of them practicing
backstage a minute ago.
Let's see what they came up
with and meet them right now.
Come on over, guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hi. Nice to meet you.
-Nice to meet you.
-Thanks for being here.
Welcome.
Welcome to the show. Let's start
with contestant number one.
What is your name
and where are you from?
-My name is Zaniah, and I'm
from Louisville, Kentucky.
-Hey, Zaniah, welcome.
-Thank you.
-What was the title of the song
you were given?
-"Stuck on a Ski Lift
with Jennifer Coolidge."
-Oh. Fantastic.
And what instrument will you
be playing for this?
-The guitar.
-The guitar. Go get set up.
Thank you very much
for being here.
I appreciate it.
Get ready. Get to the stage.
Get in the zone. I love this.
Alright.
Right now, ladies and gentlemen,
here to perform
the world premiere of
the soon-to-be classic
"Stuck on a Ski Lift with
Jennifer Coolidge," it's Zaniah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Who would have known I'd be
in Utah, Salt Lake City ♪
♪ It's winter break and finally
tryin' something exciting ♪
♪ Well, so I thought it was,
went skiing for some fun ♪
♪ Next thing you know I'm stuck
30 feet up above ♪
♪ Now I'm stuck on a ski lift
with Jennifer Coolidge ♪
♪ She's so iconic,
I hope I don't sound foolish ♪
♪ Should I tell her
I love her? ♪
♪ Maybe that's way too forward ♪
♪ I should just keep it simple ♪
♪ Tell her I love
"White Lotus" ♪
♪ I'm stuck on a ski lift with
Jennifer Coolidge ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-Wow!
Fantastic! Zaniah!
I don't know how, but you made
that sound cool.
That was amazing. Alright, let's
meet contestant number two.
What is your name
and where are you from?
-My name is Darryl Rahn.
I'm from Utica, New York.
-Hey, Darryl. Utica?
Oh, my gosh, I love Utica.
Darryl, tell everyone
what your song title is.
-It's "2023
(Go to the Gym for Me)."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-And what instrument will you be
playing tonight?
-Guitar.
-Hey, there you go.
Double guitar tonight.
Fantastic.
Go on the stage and get ready,
Darryl.
Thank you for being here.
Get in the zone.
Get that inspiration.
You got to feel this one.
2023, here we go. I like this.
Ladies and gentlemen, get ready
for the world premiere of
"2023 (Go to the Gym for Me)"
by Darryl Rahn.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Woke up New Year's Day ♪
♪ Looked down at my phone ♪
♪ At all the pretty people ♪
♪ Getting ripped
and getting toned ♪
♪ I was filled
with inspiration ♪
♪ Then I turned on my TV ♪
♪ It's 2023 ♪
♪ Go to the gym for me ♪
[ Cheers ]
♪ The membership's expensive,
plus it's way too far to walk ♪
♪ And picking up my clothes
technically counts as a squat ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ But I think it's amazing
that you're doing pilates ♪
♪ It's 2023 ♪
♪ Go to the gym for me ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Why would I get on
a treadmill ♪
♪ When I could simply
sit still ♪
♪ Just breathing in the steam of
mac and cheese ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Maybe I will do a crunch
in '24 ♪
♪ But it's 2023 ♪
♪ So go to the gym for me ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yo! Come on now. Give it up
for Darryl, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Darryl Rahn.
Both of you guys, fantastic.
Now it is time to see who won.
We're going to let our audience
decide the winner.
Yeah. Aren't you lucky?
[ Laughter ]
[ Drumroll ]
Was it Zaniah?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Or was it Darryl?
It looks like we have a winner.
It is Darryl Rahn.
Congratulations, Darryl.
Darryl, you are going home with
an "I love music" sweatshirt.
-Thank you.
-You're welcome.
Also you're going to get
a notebook here
so you can write more songs,
a "Tonight Show" notebook.
-Thank you.
-And also $1,000 in there.
That's it, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Zaniah, no one goes home
empty-handed here.
You also go home with
a sweatshirt...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...that says "I love music."
-Thank you.
-And you also get a notebook
and $1,000!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about.
Keep writing! Keep performing!
Come back and be on the show
one day again.
Give it up for your two new
instant songwriters.
Stick around. We'll be right
back with Winston Duke. Come on!